- [Mark] All right, Sandy.
- [Sandy] Yes.
- [Mark] Sandy. where'd you grow up
Where are you from originally?
- [Sandy] Well, I'm from LA.
- [Mark] And you grew up with your family,
you had both parents?
- No. Not both parents.
My father was deceased and
my mom was a single parent.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- My childhood was up and down,
stayed in and out of homes,
jail group homes, things like that.
- [Mark] How did mom lose you?
- What type of mom I had?
- [Mark] No. How did your
mom lose you to the group?
- Well, drugs of course.
- [Mark] It's a common story.
- Right, common story of
black homes, priority homes.
- [Mark] Especially at that time, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So what kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I completed high school
and graduated in 2006.
So I did, I started off doing nursing
and fell in the life of
prostituting unknowingly.
(Sandy chuckles)
- [Mark] At what age?
- Age 19.
- [Mark] And how'd you start
with a pimp or on your own?
- I started on my own
doing call girls situation
and I met a friend and she said,
this guy wanted to meet us.
And before I knew I was kidnapped
by a so-called friend and her pimp.
So I end up being his hoe
and I had to go out and
make his money every day.
- [Mark] So Instead of
keeping the money yourself
you're now giving it to him?
- Every dime.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Every single dime. It was horrible.
- [Mark] So you kind of
felt pressured or guilty?
- I was definitely pressured
'cause first of all, I was kidnapped,
I was taken away from my family.
Went out for one night, a night of fun
with my friend we have some
drinks, smoke some pot.
And next thing I know
I never returned home.
- [Mark] How long did that go on?
- Went on about like five years,
all the way until I was probably 24.
- [Mark] Tell me a little
bit about that arrangement.
- The arrangement was that I needed
to make this money for him and if I didn't
that I'll be unfound,
unrecognized, basically
'cause now he owns me.
So late nights, all the way
to maybe six in the morning
I can come in the house with less
than I made probably $3,000.
If not, I guess they call
it nowadays Gorilla Pimpin.
So his name was Mr.P.
(Sandy chuckles)
Mr. P was the big, bad pimp of mine.
- [Mark] How'd you describe Mr. P?
- He was a tall, handsome gentleman.
He seemed very nice and very caring,
but inside closed doors
he was something the
world can't even describe.
He was a monster.
He would force us to do drugs such as,
crystal meth, something to relax us.
So we wouldn't feel the
things that we were doing.
We needed to step out of our person
and become a different person.
So every day I'd just
have to be someone else.
So I wouldn't feel my feelings.
So I'll go, put on
different acts and roles,
mainly I will get more of, I want to
say guys that would like to be beat
and whooped and spanked.
So, and that's how I would make my money.
(Sandy chuckles)
- [Mark] So how did you
break free from that?
- Well I met, I wanna say a
guy that was my guardian angel,
and kind of within the
same line of business.
I was gonna be a porn star
and somehow I got with this Russian guy
he wanted me to be a part
of his porn industry.
And I went down for my
testing and all that.
And I didn't pass the test. It was false.
I went to my doctor later on
that week and I had no STD.
So I end up not returning back
to the porn industry
and just kept running.
I went to San Bernardino after
that and I stayed out there
for maybe three years and I
just stayed there and laid low.
No one knew me, started my life over.
And from there, I became who I am now.
So I don't no longer do it so much.
But if I have to, push come to shove,
I do in home calls.
I have my selective
customers that I deal with.
- [Mark] What kind of guys
do you have as clients?
- Mainly white guys, meskins.
I don't deal with blacks
because I'm terrified my pimp was black.
So I'm scared of them,
somehow I'm gonna fall back in that line.
And so I deal with outer race
and I still do the demonic things where
I whip the guys, kick them in their balls,
pinch their nipples.
I do like freaky, crazy things.
- [Mark] You have a lot of
clients that like that stuff?
- Oh yeah.
(Sandy laughs)
They love it.
- [Mark] And they like a
bigger girl like yourself?
- Oh yes, they love it.
They say the bigger, the better.
(Mark laughs)
(Sandy laughs)
It's something about it.
I have a full package that they love.
Nice big boobs, nice ass.
So, I just put on the show,
put on my nice little outfits that I have,
a little leather pleather outfits
and bring my whips and my chains.
- [Mark] How is doing this
for all these years affected
the way you see men?
- I see it affected me in
seeing men as to be weak.
They're not strong anymore.
They don't care for the women.
They don't believe in
taking care of their family
I guess a man that brings the bacon home
and the wife take care of the home.
So I describe men as either weak.
- [Mark] So you respect
men less probably because?
- Yes. So the point that now I date women.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Yes I date women instead of men,
because I feel like I can't be hurt
by a woman we're both the same species
a women can hurt me and
she makes me feel better
makes me feel more secure. We're happy.
- [Mark] Yeah. Being happy is important.
- Huh?
- [Mark] Being happy is important.
- Yeah. It's very important
to live your life out here.
We have a lot of things going on now.
- [Mark] So are drugs part
of the picture for you?
- No, I no longer do drugs.
Actually I kicked them.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- So I kinda of just go off
my bubbly personality that I have.
I just keep a positive
mind, positive output
and just into another world for me.
Into a world of pleasure, pain
and fun, not paying for me
but paying for my customers
because they love it.
So it kinda heal the
pain that I have inside
'cause I get to beat on
someone and get paid for it.
- [Mark] Was there a
stuff in your childhood
that you're still dealing with today?
- [Sandy] Mainly because I
lost my dad at a young age.
Every girl needs their dads.
- [Mark] Yeah, Was there any abuse
or traumatic events in your childhood?
- [Sandy] Yeah. My mom used
to get her ass beat daily.
- [Mark] By her boyfriend?
- [Sandy] Yes.
- [Mark] And you had to watch that?
- [Sandy] Every day, every day.
And I told myself, I will never be
with a man that will beat you
because I deserve more than that.
And I ended up with a beat that would beat
the shit out of me.
Luckily I didn't lose any teeth.
That was the great part about it.
Black eyes, busted lips.
- [Mark] And because your
little niche that you've carved
out is a little different than most
of the other girls I've talked to,
you're working mostly online
and you're a bigger girl
and you probably attract a
different type of clientele.
You probably don't have
the traumatic events
from working the street so much.
- No, because right now,
as they will say BBW,
or BBS or big and sexy,
we're at the all time demand right now.
Every man wants a big woman.
Plus, they hear that our
vagina is the tightest.
(Sandy laughs)
It never lose its form.
- [Mark] What kind of money
do you make doing that?
- I make anywhere between 1500 or 1000
depending on what they want.
- [Mark] A day?
- An hour.
- [Mark] An hour?
- Yeah.I Make pretty good money.
- [Mark] Wow.
- So that's how I'm
able to pay for my car.
- [Mark] Are you saving money?
- No.
- [Mark] No. So how do you
make that kind of money
but not save it?
- Well, I live a life where
I want to spend money.
I'm not gonna die with it,
so I don't wanna save any.
At this moment I'm working on saving.
- [Mark] What personality
traits do you have
that you think help you?
What are you happiest about
or proudest of in your life?
- What am I proud of,
that knowing am a mom.
- [Mark] Are you confident?
- I'm very confident.
I have no insecurities anymore.
I don't think that I'm a
big fat, ugly white girl
like most big woman would
think in my size and my shape.
I know that I'm beautiful.
I have a lot to offer and
not just with my legs,
with who I am as a person.
I have great different
communication skills.
I took on a lot of different
jobs as in customer service,
parking and the health field.
So I just went ahead and
succeeded in my career
and kept going. I never looked back.
- [Mark] It sounds like
you don't get depressed
about this career choice of yours?
- No, because I feel like
if I'm gonna get depressed
about it, then I give him the
power over me. So I refuse.
- [Mark] So like these men
are giving you a little
more self-esteem and power.
- Yeah
- [Mark] Than the typical arrangement.
- Oh yeah.
I got a lot of, and then
sometimes I get sad.
At a point I became a cutter.
So I did start cutting on myself
because I didn't no longer
wanted to do it anymore.
- [Mark] This was recent?
- Yeah. Recent.
I have recent cuts on my body from it,
as of these nice beautiful legs of mines
decided to cut them.
- [Mark] Oh wow. You have a lot of scars.
- Yeah.That was just to heal my pain
in the inside that made me feel better.
Which is weird to watch yourself
bleed and to harm yourself
to make you feel good.
So if I get depressed,
this is something I do.
But you know, I try to fight it off
because that is another addiction of mine.
- [Mark] And did you have children?
- Yes. I have two.
- [Mark] How old are they?
- 16 and four.
- [Mark] And Did you raise them?
- Yeah. For the most
part, I have raised them.
I raised them on, believe it or not.
A lot of people will think
being in my line of business
you wouldn't be a good mom,
but I'm an excellent mom.
Everyday I do lessons with my kids
try to teach them more than I was taught.
- [Mark] Do you think
they know you do this?
No. They have no idea.
- [Mark] They might know.
- Yes, they might.
Most definitely. They might know.
And that has been the shameful part of it.
That's why I always did in closed doors.
So I wouldn't be out on the corner.
- [Mark] Right. Do you
think you're addicted
to the fast money of this lifestyle?
- Yeah, tax-free.
- [Mark] Tax-free too.
Yeah. That's a big part.
- That's the big part.
I don't have to give my money
to the government at all.
I don't know where it's gonna be spent.
How is it gonna be spent?
So of course it's not being spent
on our society because look at it.
It's horrible.
So I love it. Fast money, fast living.
I get to get the things I want,
buy the things my kids want.
So I feel happy about it.
- [Mark] Yeah. Do you ever
stand back and look at your life
and just think, "Jesus, what am I doing?"
- Oh, every day. That's a part of my life.
Like, come on, do I want my kids to fall
in this type of lifestyle
that I'm portraying
and I'm at home teaching
them how to be young women
and young lady and their mom out here
letting her body be free for the public.
- [Mark] You have two daughters?
- Yeah. Two daughters.
- [Mark] Yeah. So what do you think
if one day you saw one of your daughters
following your footsteps?
- Well, I believe not to judge because
if I judge her that will put more pressure
on her and I'll just let her be free
'cause everyone needs to
learn how to fall one day,
if you don't fall, you
don't become strong.
- [Mark] What do your girls
think you do for a living?
- Well, they only see mommy
go to her nursing job.
So that's all they see on the day.
- [Mark] And have you been in love before?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And this.
- My first child's father
- [Mark] Does doing sex work on the side
get to complicate these relationships.
- He never knew.
- [Mark] He never knew?
- I was very great at hiding it.
But him being a cheater made
me fall deeper into the life.
So, and I broke up soon.
We were together for six and a half years.
I was young when I met him.
So me being young, having
a baby at a young age
of course I thought I was in love.
I was so in love with this guy.
Like he was the world to me.
He meant everything.
But when I found out he had abusive traits
it caused me to turn to be the abuser.
So men never abuse women
because sometimes some women
turn out to be the abuser.
So I started beating his ass
because I cannot take
any blows, any more hits,
anymore snatching me in the
throat and pulling my hair
forcing me to have sex and enjoy it.
I couldn't take it.
- [Mark] What was the
craziest request you've had
from one of your clients?
- I had the craziest request
was for me to defecate
on him and rub it over their body.
I just couldn't,
(Sandy laughs)
even though he was paying
a pretty good penny
but I just
- [Mark] You said no?
- No, I couldn't do it, and play in it?
I don't know what's sexy about that.
- [Mark] I don't either,
(Sandy chuckles)
crazy world.
- Very crazy.
- [Mark] All right Sandy,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Likewise. Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck out there.